we just got an emergency call we're up
here in Big Bear California
there has been an alert there has been a
Squatch sighting we're out here we were
gonna get this done and today might be
the day that we actually find him I have
assembled an amazing team I'm gonna let
me I gotta prep my things Jenna
brought these hedges
my prepared
I am the stealth manager he said what's
your name why you don't need to know my
name that's in the stealth manager I
need to stay some stealth II because you
never know up what could happen in these
woods with the squashes and stuff
sup guys I'm Jenna Sasquatch aficionado
it's been a couple years since we've
been doing this and over those years I
haven't actually figured out what the
Sasquatch aficionado is or does but
we've been practicing we're in a new
location and I feel like this is gonna
be the one that we find Bigfoot because
we've literally looked everywhere else
so let's go yes we have yes we have
welcome
there last time I've been developing
some new technology this is what we like
to call the Squatch tena all you have to
do is plug the antenna into with this
magical device of which I cannot tell
you how it works because then you will
copy my technology and you'll find
Squatch before me pull it up in the air
swing it around like you do you care now
yes I do care we gotta go this way
I found something I found something
Jenna police can't investigate something
sponge Evans he's here again he's
horizontal marks
what are those so what happened was this
used to be house watch nest he would lay
down like this probably was cover at one
point it's exposed now this is obviously
probably about six to nine months old
oh that's how long it takes to make a
baby there's probably a Squatch baby
this could have been this could have
potentially been a mating area have any
more of them let's carry on I don't know
the gestation period of a sasquatch I'm
not actually sure if anyone does because
I don't know if he's really hot why is
your mouth yeah he put his real I've
seen him I've seen him with my own two
eyes shun the non-believers shunned and
non-believers Charlie not like these men
here I spoiled again
it's me it's when I say to Squatch I was
this Adele wrote the song about me and
my relationship with sasquatch God she
knows my feelings like it's like she
knows me
hello it's me
I've been waiting I can't keep going on
like this give me a sign I need a sign
Oh sign it up hello my water bottle
okay got it Oh God sup man's got the top
point until next time guys
watch watch sign at home